では よろしくお願いします
えーと ダンマパダです
38からですか  佐藤さんいないですか
今 来ますけど  定期的に 3
回か分からないんですけど
ダンマパダの土曜日はね
勉強会やってますので
えーと 今日何番  38ですね
今日予定は4時半ですね
瞑想会の5時半から  では
新しい仏教を初めて参加なさってる方々も
別に初めてだからわからないということはございませんので
ダンマパダというお釈迦様の大事な言葉をまとめているところで
一個だけでも理解できるように説かれています
ですから 決して前もって勉強していないんだからわからなかったということはありえないんです
大学の科学の授業はいきなり聞いてもわからないんですけどね
中学校の時代からずっと勉強していないと
で そんな調子でこれわからないということはならないんです
ですから 頑張って理解できるようにと聞いてみてください
仏教は理解するために必要な条件は
たった一つ 真面目に聞く
真面目に聞く それでわかります
そういう不思議な教えっていうのは仏教以外はないんです
真面目に聞くだけでわかります
頭の中であまりも固定概念でね
私こそあれ知ってる これ知ってるというふうに
まあそこで壁作っているとわからなくなりますが
そうではなくて どんなことを勉強してあっても
人が喋るものは素直に聞くのは常識ですからね
信じるか信じないかっていうのは後の話で
認めるか認めないかっていうのは
それまた後の 話を聞かないで
私は認めないというのはね
そういう言える権利もなくなっちゃうんです
ですから まず素直に聞く
で それで理解できる まあそれからそれをどうするのかということは
自分の自由で もう認めるか認めないかっていうのは
その各人の自由なんです
では 始まります 38番目
Anavattita cittassa saddhammam avijānato, pariplava pasadas
a paññā paripūreti.
39番目  Anavassuta cittassa ananvāta cetaso, puññapāpā pahīn
assa nati jāgarato
bhayaṃ. Anavassuta cittassa ananvāta cetaso, puñ
ñapāpā pahīnassa nati jāgarato
bhayaṃ. という2つあの
[ため息]ではそれから普通に説明していきます
この 2つはこのパンニャ智慧という仏教は推薦している
人間の道徳と言えば道徳で
徳と言えば徳で 人間どうしても身につけなくちゃいけないものがあります
パンニャと言うんですね
それはパンニャっていうのは日本語で言えば智慧です
で 仏教も他の宗教と同じだと見るならば
世の中にいろいろ宗教ありまして
仏教はもう一つだと そうやって同じ枠に入れて考えるならば
まあキリスト教は神を信仰することを推薦しているし
信仰  faith というものは一番唯一の大事なことで
神を信じる イスラム教になってくると
また唯一な条件は神を信じる
でも あっちこちらにいる神を信じてもこれはダメで
その自分たちが名前を挙げている神が唯一の絶対的な神だと
もう絶対的な条件で もう全く変わらない条件で信じると
それから教えを理解していけばいいと
そうやってこの宗教では
まず信仰という この絶対的な尺度
ガイドラインをつけておくんですね
その場合は 他宗教の場合は
この唯一な神 唯一な神という連中も何人かいるんですけど
各宗教によってそれぞれ違うんですけど
みんな互いに自慢して
私こそ神やというふうに
それは我々の解決できないもので
どちらが本物の神かということはね
だからそれはもう互いに殺し合いするしか方法ないんです
だからたくさん殺して勝った人の神が正しいんです
そういうふうに歴史は流れているんです
それで この絶対的な この人は絶対的な神である
この人が天地創造したものであって
我々はこの人に創造されたんだと
で まず信じる それからあれこれあれこれでごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃいろんなものが聖書という書類の中であるんですね
そこは本当のもう本当がないかということを判断する基準が
神が言ったならば本当であって
いかに人間の理屈に合っても合わなくてもしょうがないんだ
例えば女性がもう何か女の他の男の人に喋ったならば
もう石を投げて殺すべきだと神が書いているんだったら
ちょっと喋っただけで何のこともないのではないかというふうに
人間の理屈は通じないんです
もう神を信じている場合は
それは絶対通じないんです
ですから 結構女の人なんかは
こういうイスラム系の国々では殺されますよ
で 何と言いますか 邪な行為はね
男にも禁止していますけど
男は石を投げて殺しません
女は殺そうというふうな
いろいろまああります
それ なんでそういうことをわざわざ言うんでしょうかというと
我々人間の目から見ると
平等じゃない しかし 神が言ったんだからしょうがないんですね
そうやってまず信仰というものは固定しておいて
その信仰という基準で善悪判断をする
我々の生き方を決める
というのは宗教の世界なんですね
それで あ じゃあ仏教もない宗教ではないかという場合は
まあ言いたければ言ってもよろしいし
それで仏教になってくると
仏教はもうとにかくいったっ
こういう状態に至ってくださいと
達しなさいという精神的な状態を語っているんです
この精神的な状態は何なのかというと
智慧というものなんですね
だから智慧を開発しなさいと
信仰ではないんですね
信じなさい 信じなさい
信じなさい 私が偉いんだぞというふうにことは言わない
お釈迦様も言うんですよ
私こそ偉いんだよと でも違うところは
ただ単なる話聞きなさいよと
ただそのために言うんです
私こそ唯一偉いんだよと
私が言っていることには
逆らえる人間も人間どころか神も誰もいないんだよと
できれば逆らってみなさいよと
違うんだと言いなさいよと
というふうにすごいチャレンジで言うんです
それが私を信じなさいという意味じゃないんです
いい加減話聞きなさいと
知ってるつもりですか
と という あのちょっとした教師のね
狂暴な態度なんです 教師なんだよ
お釈迦様は だから 生徒たちには決して甘くないんです
厳しく当たるんです いい加減にしなさいと
話聞きなさい 信じなさいということはないんです
だからまず話を聞きなさいというところで
先生として自分の資格を言ってるんです
私には私は絶対的な資格を持っているんだと
私に並べられる先生は他いないんだと
それであるならば もう真面目にその先生のところで勉強するしかないでしょうに
そこから逃げちゃったって
もうろくでもない先生のところで勉強しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
そういうことだから 真面目に聞きなさいというところでお釈迦様も私こそすごい偉いんだということを言ってます
それで我々は話を聞いてみる
話を聞いてみると お釈迦様は我々に何をおっしゃってますかというと
あんた方はみんなもう無知だと
何の判断もできない 生き方もわからない
何のために生きてるのかさっぱりわからない
ただ単にこのあの群れで生活する動物のように
もう前にやってる人がやってることをやってるだけの生き方ではないかと
だからこの無知を破って智慧というものを経験しなさいと
ということで 智慧というものを教えるんですね
智慧は教えられるものではないんです
それは自分たちが達する精神的な状態なんですね
智慧の開発 ですから 仏教は智慧の教えでもありますし
ブッダという言葉さえも智慧の達人
達成 完成者という意味でもあるし
ブッダっていうのはもう簡単に言えばわかった人って意味なんですよ
わかった人っていう意味で
からわかったっていうことは
真理をわかりましたと経験しました
わかりましたと いわゆる智慧でいえば智慧を完成しましたと
だから自分が智慧を完成して
我々にも智慧を完成する道を教えているんです
その道になってくると
自分でやらなくちゃいけない
そういうことで宗教と似ているんですが
かなりまあ異質的な宗教なんです
結構自由で 一人一人の人の努力によって結果を得られる教えなんですね
ごまかしはなかなか効かない
各人が自分が努力する分はまあ幸せになる
そこで智慧を完成したならば
もう完璧な幸福を得られるんだということで
で この三十八 三十九っていうのは
この智慧について あのまあ
ちょっとしたことを語られているところなんです
それでパーリの単語で日本語訳で説明しないんですから
いつでも原文で説明しますので
で アナワッティタ チッタッサという最初の言葉
アナワッティタ チッタッサ
このチッタッサというのは心のことですね
心ですね 心がアナワッティタっていう言葉の意味はこの不安定
いわゆる落ち着いてない
アワッティタっていうのはしっかりと定めている
しっかりと確定しているという意味なんですね
アナワッティタというと
そちらの反対の言葉で
不安定な心 揺らいでいる心
はっきりしていない心
優柔不断の心なんですね
そこへ行った途端 これは私は大丈夫だと言える人間いないんですよ
私はなら大丈夫という人がいます？そういう人たちが
心はしっかりしているんだと
優柔不断がないんだと
悶々と悩んだりはしないんだと
しっかり物事を決めて生きてるんだというふうに
そんな人間いないと思いますけどね
人間の心っていうのはいつでも揺らいでいる
しっかりともう判断できるわけじゃないんです
何かに決めても 自分がもう捨てたものについてはまだまだ惜しいなという気持ちもある
時々いくつかの選択があって
何かに決めなくちゃいけない
それで悩んで悩んで悩んで
もうどうしようもないところで一つは決めますけど
決めても捨てた選択についても
やっぱりまだまだ惜しいなという気持ちも残っている
そんなもんで心は安定するわけじゃないんです
そこで何かに決めようと思ったところで
外からまた別な誰か何か言われたら
また考え方が揺らぐんです
それが人間の心っていうことなんです
大体人間の心っていうのは揺らいでいるんです
いつでも不安定なんです
もう考えてるって言っても
もう切りがなく考えてるんです
論理的にしっかりと考えるってことはない
論理的にしっかりと考える場合は
もうそんなに考え方は長くないんです
結論が出て そこで終わっちゃうんです
何か考えて結論が出たら
その人すごく楽しいんです
その場合は すごく楽しくて
満足感があって もうごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃさらに考えることはしない
でも人間はそうじゃなくて
もう何かそれ自慢してるんですね
曖昧で中途半端で もう何も決められない状態でいることこそ素晴らしい人間やというふうな
俗世間が自慢までしているんですね
だからそれは私の単語を言語に入れ替えてみれば
私は何もできないアホであると
それこそ素晴らしい 風なことで「君たちもアホになりなさいよ」と
自分の弱みを正当化して
他人にも同じ弱みを推薦するような世界なんです
それは俗世間の人間にとっては安心です
自分が何か法律を犯しているならば
できれば自分の仲間も同じ法律を何か法律違反した方が安全なんです
そうすると自分のことを批判したりしないし
自分をバラしたりもしない
大体世の中っていうのはそうやって悪い方向へと引っ張るんです
自分が悪いことをしているんだから
あなたもやりなさいと
私は頭が悪いんだからね
頭の悪い方がいいでしょうと
逆を認めないんですね
例えば私はだらしなくて
すぐすぐもう決まり法律破っちゃいますから
誰かがしっかりした人と付き合いたいとはないんです
私があほなことをやろうとすると
もう強引にそれをやめさせてくれる
あるいはもうバラして
私をもう法律に裁く 裁くようにはめてくれる友達がいれば
もうこんなに悪いことをしないんではないかなと
そういうふうに自分を上達させようという気持ちはないんです
だから 堕落するように仲間を探したりする
それで自慢はしていますけどね
頭の悪さを 頭の悪さを自慢していたっても
自分が成長しないし 自分の周りの人々も成長しないし
もう結果として社会全体
世界全体も良くなるわけじゃないんです
だから この単純なことさえもいまだかつて世界知らないんですよ
仏教は単純に見えますけど
全て大胆な教えなんです
これ 単純に見えてるんじゃなくて
お釈迦様が絶対的な先生だから
どんなバカにもわかるように語っているだけの話なんです
どんな無知な人にも理解できるように語っています
そのお釈迦様の想像を絶する智慧のおかげで
我々は仏教を軽視しているんです
あべこべなんです なんだ仏教ってこんなもんですかね
教えているのはとか そういうことでは
これもまたとんでもない誤解でね
これぐらいすごい真理をね
すごい簡単に語られているんです
だから世界全体見てみると
精神的な安定っていうのは誰にもない
精神的な不安定な人に唯一なわらにすがるということがありますね
わらにすがるような感じで信仰にすがるんです
誰かを信じて その人に身を投げて
その人の奴隷になって
言われる通りにする そうすると自分では責任を持つ必要はないんです
人間というのはいつでも責任を持てない
持ちたくない ただロボット人生やりたいんですよ
だからみんなすっごく安定しますよ
もうしっかりした何か仕事があって
もう上司がいて もうはい
右ではじゃあ左とかね
そうやって仕事を任せてくれると
もうずいぶん元気よくやるんですね 「
その箱を４つをこちら右側にあるタンスの左側の３番目の段に入れてください」と言うと 「
あれ 右ってどこですか？右左ではないところは右」というふうにいろいろ考えて
もうなんとか入れる それでいい仕事をしたと
ただのロボットなんですけど
大体人間というのはそういう生き方は好きなんです
で そうなっているのはなぜかというと
自分で判断して自分で考えて生きると言ったっても
これはもうあまりにもできるわけじゃない
何も分かってないんだから
それで そもそも我々は何も分かってない
不安定な状態でいるんだから
誰かが親分がいた方が
よろしい それで子分になって言われる通りにする
その悪循環は未だに変わってないんです
これからの世界はそういう悪循環で生きようとしているんです
そちらにはまた単純数学的なミスがあるんです
これ数学の方程式のようなものだから
この方程式自体にミスがあっちゃうと
いくらそれ使っても使っても結果がダメなんです
どういうミスがあるかというと
もともと人間というのは不安定であるならば
私が不安定であると誰かに聞いてみたら
その人も不安定なんですね
お父さんに聞いてみたってもすごい不安で
では母親どうでしょうか
でも母親も不安で 周り誰見たっても
みんなもうなんか知って生きてるわけじゃないんです
それであるならば 我々は親分を選ぶんだけど
なんでその親分だけ不安定でないんですかね
人間みんな精神的な優柔不断だったら
親分として選ぶ人も優柔不断であるはずなんです
そこを調べないで子分になるんです
もう何かもう格好良かったとかね
話は面白かったとかで
もう何とかでいいんです
その数学的な見られるこのケース
この計算のこの方程式のミスをね
お釈迦様は随分簡単に言うんですよ
だってあるところでね
みんな神々を拝んでますけどね
助けて 助けてまえ 守りたまえとかね
拝んでいるんですけど
そういう連中すごい不安定だと
怯えているんだと 優柔不断だと
だから優柔不断な人のところに行って
私の弱みを何とかしてちょうだいと言ったってもできるわけないでしょうに
だからそこはそう教えているのは
この人に我々は依存する前に
その人が依存するぐらいの資格があるかないかと
で 調べないと 命を捨ててはいけないんだと
だから人は絶対捨ててはいけないものは何でしょうかと
仏教は何でも捨てなさいと言うんです
迷惑だから捨てて自由になった方がいいんだと言うんだから
ある日お釈迦様にこの質問出されたんです
では釈尊に聞きますけど
人は絶対捨ててはいけないものは何でしょうか？と言うと
お釈迦様の答え単純です
単純です 自分を捨ててはならぬ
それで自分を捨てるということはものすごく意味が複雑なんですが
我々は誰かに依存するということは自分を捨てることなんです
誰かを信じる ということは自分を捨てることなんですね
それで 自分を決して捨ててはならない自分を誰かのために捨てる場合は
その価値がありますかと
ちょっと調べないとあまりにも無知なんですね
品物は何ですかとさっぱり知ろうとしないで買うんですかね
例えば自分の全財産で
財産で何か一回だけの買い物をする
家も土地ももう銀行貯金ももうあるあるってるものは全部もう払って
その場合は何を買うんですかね
え？何でもいいんだからということにならないでしょうに
買う品物はまるっきり調べないで
全財産を投げて買うわけじゃないでしょうに
そんなことってのは 人間が普通はしないんです
同じ品物をこの店で 1,000円で
隣の店で 1,200円で売っただけでも
我々はあれこれ何でしょうかと調べるでしょうに
皆様どうか分かりませんだけど
私なら調べる 私は堂々と聞く
あのお店でこれは 1,000円ですけど
なんであんた 1,200円で売ってるんでしょうかと
その人の訳を聞く そこで安く売ってる店に行って
なんでこれこんなにどこでも定価もこの値段で
あのお店 この店 どこへ行ってもせいぜい 1割 1. 5割しか下げてないのに
あんたはなんでこれぐらい値段下げて売ってるんですか？と言うと
その店の店員が何か説明するんですよ
その説明によって買うか買わないかと決める
時々同じ品物を半額でやる場合もありますね
ある店ではそれを普通の値段で売ったりして
ただ単に半額だから買うではなくて
で 私にお金あるんだから半額では買わないんだぞと
俺がプライド高いんだからって
そういうどちらでも正しいことも正しくない
どちらでもないんで 自分でやっぱり考えなくちゃいけないんですね
半額で売ってるものは
例えば展示品ですと 展示品だと知って
自分にとっては少々使えればいいんだと
そんなにお金もこれに捨てたくないんだと判断したら
展示品買ってもいいでしょうし
少々ちょっとした傷があっても
それで嫌な気持ちにはなりません
でも 自分がしっかりしたもの
大事な仕事があって どうしても必要なもので
途中で壊れたら困るとか場合は
半額のものを買うんじゃなくて
もうしっかりした新品を買った方がいいし
シールは自分で開けると
工場から直接来て だからどちらにどんな買い物をするのかという場合は
我々は普通だったらやっぱり調べる
何でもいいんだから売ってくださいという状態にはならないんですね
でも 人間が自分の精神の世界になってくると
自分の大事な命になってくると
全く無知な商売をするんです
普段絶対やらない商売をするんです
何かを信仰して自分を投げる
そちらに 信仰は悪くないんです
決して悪くないんです
だって もともと何もわからないんだから
人に聞いてもらわなきゃ
だから信仰というものは取り消せませんよ
信仰を信じるということは
人間には必要な条件です
なのに この使い方なんなのかと
だから信仰する前に 我々は親分を決める前に親分になる資格あるかないか
この人を信じても大丈夫ですか？と
調べる必要があります
こんなのは簡単にわかります
例えば私が絶対的な神だぞと
私こそは全部作ったぞとと言ってる場合でも
ちょっと言ってる言葉を見てみると
そう言ってるでしょ？聖書に
聖書っていうのはたくさんありますからね
いろんな人ももうもう今
この 50年間でも新しい聖書はいくつかもヨーロッパであちこち作ったりもしてますよ
だから聖書っていうのはたくさんありますよ
で 私は絶対的な神で全部作りましたよと言いながら
次に何言うんですかね
あなた方の生き方は間違ってるんだと
私を信じなきゃダメやと
悪の道歩んでるんだぞと言った途端
それ逆に質問されてされるでしょうね
我々は悪の道歩んでるんだったら
それはお前のせいではないかと
だって作った機械には欠陥がある
それは機械のせいだという理屈でしょ
機械に欠陥がありきというならば
私なら作った人を殴るんです
あんたが悪いんだと だからそれをだから三菱が作った車にとんでもない欠陥があったところで
堂々と買った人が悪いと言っていたでしょ
そういう理屈で生きていていいんでしょうかと
三菱会社は間違ってない
トランスミッションに問題が
それはあなたが悪いんだと買った人に言うんです
作ってるの作ったの俺たちだよと
これは欠陥であんたが悪いという理屈です
バスのね 車輪のハブがもう構造上問題があって
で 人を潰して殺しちゃうでしょうに
それはその買った人が悪い
という理屈 これでずっと生きてるんです
人間は 全然気づかないんですよ
いかにバカかということには
だからこの人を信じるのはいいことですよ
決して悪く悪いことじゃないんです
信じる前にその人のその資格があるかないか調べるところで
我々はこの計算ミスをしているんです
だから信仰という数学では何かあの変わらない値でしょ
これでもBでもでも何でもいいんですけど
でもに当たる値価値がね
そちらに問題があるんです
ですから このお釈迦様はそこら辺を我々に注意させるんです
だからその時点でも 人類もかって昔からいまだ今までやっている
ずっとやっている ある変な生き方
もう絶対あってはならない生き方を直してるんです
信じる前に調べなさいと
信仰は悪いとは言わない
できないできないという必要はない
見ればすぐ分かりますよと
すぐ分かります  [背景音楽]で
それでこのお釈迦様がこの智慧というものは信仰ではなくて
智慧というものは あの
人間に必要なものであって
それはもともとない もう当たり前
わかっている 人間生まれつき信仰を持って生まれるというふうに言ってるんですけど
そんなことはない 我々は生まれる時は無知で何もわからない
しかし 毎日成長するんでしょうし
成長するということも確定していない
自分の生き方によって成長したりしなかったり
変な方向へ成長したり
いろいろあります しかし
何らかは成長する だったらそこら辺はきちんと管理して正しく成長するようにするのは普通です
その場合は だったら必ずしも身につけなくちゃいけない絶対的な必要なものに成長すればいいということで智慧を開発するという言葉が出てきます
そういうわけで 仏教は智慧の宗教なんです
信仰の宗教ではない といっても
信仰を馬鹿にしているわけでもない
大事な人だったら 信頼できる人だったら信仰する
そういう条件付き あんたは大事な人
信頼できる人 導くことできる人
悪いことをしない人であるならば信じるという条件なんです
そこで信仰対象はその条件に合わないと発見した時点で信仰はしない
そこら辺は欠けてますよ
皆様の社会からまた例で言えば
例えば麻原という人が唯一の解脱者と最終解脱者とで言っていたところで
日本にて一番判断能力のない東大京大とかで卒業
卒業している若者が信じたんですね
そこまでは間違いを起こしているわけじゃないんです
もともとあの若者っていうのは自分で勉強して勉強できない
ただもう鵜呑みに住み込み教育だから
住み込みっていうのは
私はこの清掃者の仕来りなんです
脳細胞は浅くる清掃者と同じ
清掃者じゃない ゴミ収集者
ゴミ収集者にはもうただ入れるだけで全部潰して中に入れるんです
だからこのゴミ収集者の方程式でできている頭の細胞で生まれて
結構いい大学には入ります
が この 何がいいか何が悪いかという判断ができない
それでそういう若い人々はね
まずそこに入りました
そこまでは文句言えないんですよ
そちらも精神的なことも知りたいと思っているんだから
そこでその人はやっぱり信仰に値しないと
会ったその日から見えるはずなんです
私も会っていることがあるんだから
会う前にも資格ないとわかるし
会っただけでもなんだこの人は
という それでもものすごくそんなことがあっても
そんなことがあってもと寄りくつれるんです
その方が最終解脱したと言ってるんだから信じるんだと
こういう悪いこと そんなことしたってもということ
それだったらもう人殺したっても何やったっても
あの信仰は変わらない信仰になるんです
いまだに信じているという
だからその人間の脳細胞にあるこの問題
理性がない それで皆様方はそれはある一部の人々やと言って
私は何の問題もないと手を振りたいでしょう
これが良くないんですよ
同じ人間だから この頭にあるこのプログラムをすっごく改良しなくちゃいけないんです
私たちはそんなことを問題を起こしてないと言っても
私はあなたはその人に会わなかったんだからでしょという反論するんです
そういう機会がなかったんだから
バカなことをやる機会がなかったんだからやってないだけで
バカなことをする罪を犯す機会があったらやるんだよと
そういうことで 私は安全だということは成り立たないんです
それで信仰は悪くないんですが
信仰は条件の中でやるもんです
そこで信仰対象に値する人がその条件がないと
その資格は揃ってないと分かったところで
もう信仰はやめる で そういうふうな生き方はしなくちゃいけない
我々はこの一生の中で間違った人を信じて
いろんなひどい目に遭うということは
これはそっちもあるかもしれませんよ
ある人を信じたところでかなり騙されたとかね
また別な人を信じ始めたら
その人にも騙されたとかね
それは別に問題じゃないんです
で 信じるためにその資格ないなと分かった時点で自分を身を引かなくちゃいけない
その性格だったら たまたま間違ったってもどうったことないんです
たまたま変な人を信仰してバカなことをやったりしたったと言っても
すぐ自分で分かったらやめますからね
だから自由に生きる前に
その自由に生きる訓練というかね
資格というか それは身についてないと
いわゆる運転する前に教習所に行って
運転の技を身についてないと
できるわけじゃないんです
教習所で運転の技を教えてくれたら
教習所はごちゃごちゃ文句言わないよ
あんた こういう車しか運転してはいけませんよとかね
自分が好きな車に乗って運転したっても
それは大丈夫です だから一応そういうことで
信仰は否定しているでしょうかと言えば否定していない
では肯定しているのかというと
そんな簡単に肯定しているわけでもありません
なぜかというと もともと智慧を開発することが目的であって
智慧を開発するために必要であるならば
人は信じる だから人を信じる前に
その人に智慧があったらいいんでありがたいんですよ
智慧がある人 智慧は完成した人であるならば
もうその人を信じるしか道がないんです
で 完成しているんだから間違いは起こせませんし
その人は完全に正しくガイドして上達できるようにはする
そこまでこの芸文に対するこの
まあ序論ですけど  [終始背景音楽]